[Música]
en Estados Unidos el FBI arrestó al
Principal sospechoso de la filtración de
los documentos del pentágono se trata
del líder del grupo online de Gamers
religiosos y aficionados a las armas
donde se publicaron por primera vez los
archivos el hombre de 21 años era
miembro de la inteligencia de la guardia
aérea conectamos con Washington
en Francia jornada número 12 de
protestas contra la reforma pensional de
Manuel macron Los sindicatos convocaron
las marchas un día antes de que el
consejo constitucional decida sobre la
legalidad del texto según el gobierno la
participación cayó a menos de 400.000
personas en todo el país tenemos
análisis
en un discurso ante el parlamento de la
República de Irlanda el presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden pidió a Reino
Unido que trabaje más de cerca con
dublín para evitar el resurgimiento del
conflicto en Irlanda del Norte
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
Mateo y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos esta edición en Estados Unidos
con la que es una de las noticias del
día y es que el FBI ha detenido a un
sospechoso por la filtración masiva de
documentos secretos del pentágono se
trata de un hombre de 21 años
identificado como
miembro de la inteligencia de la guardia
aérea de Massachusetts y que lideraba el
grupo online de Gamers religiosos y
aficionados a las armas donde se
publicaron por primera vez los archivos
clasificados antes de propagarse por
otros portales de internet conectamos
ahora con Cristóbal Vázquez en
Washington Cristóbal Buenas tardes de
nuevo que más a detalles se saben del
perfil del sospechoso
Este joven tenía 21 años usted lo decía
si aparte de el grupo de inteligencia de
la guardia Nacional del Estado de
Massachusetts Este joven entró a la
guardia nacional aérea desde el 2019 y
desde el año pasado ha estado
compartiendo imágenes de información
confidencial en esta red social de la
cual personas integrantes de este grupo
que él lideraba en esta red social dicen
que él ya era el que lideraba este grupo
algunos de los integrantes de este grupo
de red social lo describen como una
persona carismática hay que mencionar
que esta red social se llama discord y
esta red es la que se usan mucho en los
juegos online los Gamers usan esta red
social para compartir su información lo
que han dicho algunos de los integrantes
de este grupo que lideraba
Este joven estaba compartiendo
información más que para revelar de
alguna forma secretos de estado lo
estaba haciendo más para impresionar a
los otros jóvenes que hacían parte de
esta comunidad de Gamers en donde se
compartían información Así que estos
jóvenes han sido
han querido hablar y han compartido su
versión de cómo era Este joven que ahora
está está arrestado y pues eh pronto lo
procesarán en la justicia
Cristóbal pero al margen no del objetivo
que tuviera el sospechoso a la hora de
compartir estos documentos el pentágono
ha calificado los hechos como un acto
criminal deliberado Qué consecuencias
legales enfréntate sheira el sospechoso
grandes consecuencias legales por cada
documento que fue filtrado Se podría
seguir a afrontar hasta diez años de
cárcel es decir podría incluso llegar
hasta la cadena perpetua contando la
cantidad de documentos que se filtraron
que pusieron en en la lupa las las
actividades de espionaje de Estados
Unidos y obviamente lo que está diciendo
el fiscal general el departamento de
Justicia es que pues será acusado de
espionaje el acta de espionaje que no
solamente pone en riesgo la seguridad de
Estados Unidos sino que le da ventaja
con esta información a enemigos de
Estados Unidos así que diez años por
cada papel que fue filtrado podría
afrontar Este joven por haber filtrado
estos documentos que efectivamente como
lo dice el pentágono independientemente
de cual haya sido la motivación de haber
compartido información confidencial pues
no se justifica y lo que están diciendo
muchos acá en Washington en el congreso
en la casa blanca incluso biden desde
Irlanda dijo que tiene que haber una
revisión exhausta exhaustiva sobre
Cuáles son los mecanismos para acceder a
esta información y quién exactamente
está accediendo a esta información
confidencial que termina en la mano de
pues adultos jóvenes como termina
compartiéndolo en redes sociales y se
termina siendo viral bueno Cristóbal
Muchas gracias por el reporte estaremos
muy atentos a toda la investigación
acerca de esta filtración nosotros
continuamos en Estados Unidos porque ahí
avanza la batalla legal por el acceso a
las píldoras abortivas el fiscal general
anunció que el departamento de Justicia
va a recurrir ante la Corte Suprema la
decisión de ayer de un tribunal de
apelaciones que preservó temporalmente
el acceso a la píldora pero con
restricciones con este proceso Además
está en juego La autoridad de la fda
para imponer el criterio científico en
la autorización de medicamentos
también en Estados Unidos este jueves el
expresidente Donald Trump será
interrogado por la fiscal general de
Nueva York Leticia James en el marco de
una investigación por lo civil por
supuesto fraude de 250 millones de
dólares con su empresa recordemos que el
pasado 3 de abril Trump quien aspira de
nuevo a la presidencia en 2024 se
convirtió en el primer ex presidente de
Estados Unidos en ser imputado con
cargos penales en el caso de presuntos
pagos para comprar el silencio de una
actriz porno además acumula varias
investigaciones preliminares en su
contra por supuesto mal manejo de
documentos clasificados y por intentar
interferir en los resultados electorales
de 2020 entre otras cuestiones
vamos ahora a Francia porque allí se
desarrolló la jornada número 12 de
protestas contra la impopular reforma de
las pensiones de Manuel macron un día
antes de que el consejo constitucional
decida si el texto está amparado por la
Constitución de la quinta República
francesa según el Ministerio del
interior
380.000 personas habrían participado
este jueves en las protestas a nivel
nacional Mientras que el sindicato sgt
eleva la cifra a más de un millón En
todo caso ha habido una bajada de la
participación respecto a la jornada
anterior conectamos ahora con el
analista político florián laferte
florián Buenas tardes para usted le
empiezo planteando Hoy era una de las
últimas oportunidades del movimiento
para dar una demostración de fuerza y
sin embargo ha caído la participación A
qué cree que se debe Esta caída
ya estamos a dos meses de protestas es
muchísimo tomando en cuenta además que
es un contexto de inflación bastante
fuerte en Europa y en Francia Entonces
esta gente no puede estar estar
Eternamente en las calles pero lo que no
se puede esconder es que a pesar de esta
bajada de movilización que quizás
también es una una un cambio también del
modo de protestación lo que podemos
decir es que la frustración general es
muy fuerte mucho más fuerte que antes y
que la oposición a este proyecto sigue
manteniendo a un nivel muy alto y
floriana ahora hablaremos no de la
frustración social Pero antes abordemos
el hecho de que mañana el consejo
constitucional decidirá si este texto
está amparado por la Constitución qué
puntos de la ley podrían ser declarados
inconstitucionales
hay dos solicitudes que fueron
presentadas durante el consejo de el
consejo constitucional el primero es por
los diputados de de izquierda que y de
extrema derecha que contesta los
posibles o que llamamos nosotros los
vehículos legislativos este tratan de
artículos que no tendrían nada que ver
con el propósito de un proyecto de ley
que es un proyecto de ley
presupuestarial y el segundo es uno de
una solicitud que viene de los senadores
de izquierda que crítica el límite del
debate impuesto por el gobierno con el
uso de cuarenta y nueve punto tres es un
artículo que ya se ha hablado y que yo
mismo había mencionado aquí en Francia
24 el 442 y el 38 es la acumulación de
todos estos artículos que hubieran
limitado el debate dentro del parlamento
y que entonces perjudicarían la
legitimidad de este texto y en función
de lo que se decida mañana de lo Que
decida el consejo constitucional que
escenarios se abren para el movimiento
contra la reforma
Bueno para mí hay tres escenarios el
primero es un escenario que yo llamo ni
fuera de la Constitución ni fuera de las
manos del pueblo es decir el consejo va
a censurar parte de los artículos con
los vehículos legislativos que estaba
explicando dentro de estos el tipo de
contrato para las personas de más de 60
años y ahí lo más importante sería
salvado por el gobierno porque la edad
para jubilarse sería mantenida a los 64
años y no fuera de las manos del pueblo
porque el consejo constitucional también
puede validar la iniciativa de la
compartida es una iniciativa que está
permitida después de un cambio de dentro
de la constitución en 2009 que permite
con la solicitud de unos diputados de
impulsar un referéndum a nivel nacional
y aquí es muy importante porque si se
logra esta
ahí se votaría la cancelación de la ley
y será claramente un voto A favor o en
contra del gobierno con un riesgo
entonces de caída del ejecutivo actual
el escenario dos para mí está censura
integral pero aquí estamos sobre un
riesgo que es muy importante sería una
humillación para el gobierno actual
porque solamente se hizo 20 veces dentro
de toda la historia de la quinta
República y las consecuencias ahora no
se pueden medir porque según yo la
renuncia de la ministra sería definitiva
no habrá otra opción sobre todo porque
ya se posicionó como la la experta
quizás de la negociación y vimos el
resultado Tendremos una alianza de
izquierda que va a bloquear todo va a
imponer este bloqueo una derecha que
podría intentar una alianza con el
macroismo pero es un partido que es muy
debilitado y muy muy pequeño en
comparación al macroismo Entonces sería
decir que el patronismo tend y hacer
muchos sacrificios para tener esta
Alianza y tener la mayoría en el
parlamento y la extrema derecha que va a
seguir bloqueando igual y el tercer
escenario no es la validación del texto
en su completitud con un riesgo alto de
un divorcio de una parte del pueblo con
la con la contra las instituciones de la
quinta República eso vamos a ver después
con el nivel de movilización existe la
fuerte o no sí floriana Lamentablemente
se nos acaba el tiempo para continuar
analizando esta cuestión pero seguro que
volveremos a hablar una vez conozcamos
finalmente Cuál es el fallo del Consejo
constitucional mañana Muchas gracias
gracias Usted nosotros vamos a dublín
porque ahí en un discurso ante el
parlamento Irlandés el presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden pidió a Reino
Unido que trabaje más de cerca con la
República de Irlanda para evitar el
resurgimiento del conflicto norislandés
recordemos que vaiden emprendió una
visita oficial por la isla de Irlanda
para conmemorar los 25 años de la de los
llamados acuerdos de viernes Santo un
entendimiento mediado por Washington que
puso fin a décadas de conflicto armado
nacional religioso en Irlanda del Norte
entre los republicanos partidarios de
unirse a la República de Irlanda y los
loialistas los que quieren permanecer en
el Reino Unido
hay que preguntarnos cómo Estados Unidos
e Irlanda pueden trabajar de la mano con
Reino Unido y la Unión Europea Para
apoyar a la gente de Irlanda del Norte
pienso que Reino Unido debe trabajar más
de cerca con los irlandeses la violencia
política nunca más debe tener cabida en
esta isla
y actualizamos ahora las noticias de la
guerra en Ucrania porque ante la
petición de una mayor presencia de la
otan en el mar Negro Rusia se declara
reacia a extender el acuerdo de granos y
si se anula este acuerdo el planeta
podría enfrentar una grave crisis
alimentaria
el mar Negro como escenario clave de
confrontación en la guerra el ministro
de relaciones exteriores de Ucrania
lanzó una controversial propuesta la
otan que encendió las alarmas en Rusia
el mar Negro es fundamental para hacer
que toda Europa sea pacífica y orientada
hacia el futuro Lamentablemente el mar
Negro también es una prueba de lo rápido
que pueden deteriorarse las cosas Si se
descuidan las amenazas
propone integrar los sistemas de defensa
aérea y antimisiles ucranianos con los
aliados de La otan en el mar Negro y en
el mar Báltico este último controlado en
su mayoría por la otan y con el reciente
ingreso de Finlandia a la alianza
Rusia teme que ocurra lo mismo en el mar
Negro son marítima esencial para el
comercio y para su postura militar el
kremlin respondió a la propuesta de
culeva
el mar Negro nunca se convertirá en un
mar de la otan el mar es compartido por
todas las naciones litorales y debe ser
un mar de cooperación interacción y
seguridad la seguridad debe ser
indivisible
prueba la importancia estratégica al mar
Negro es el acuerdo de granos pactado
paralelamente por Rusia y Ucrania con la
ONU y Turquía la más reciente extensión
del pacto expirará el 18 de mayo y Rusia
se muestra renuente a extenderlo debido
a las restricciones que impiden la
salida de sus granos y fertilizantes
en el campo de batalla bacmut sigue
siendo epicentro de la guerra los rusos
afirman que controlan casi la totalidad
de la ciudad las tropas
aerotransportadas apoyan El Avance de
las tropas de asalto bloqueando el envío
de reservas del ejército ucraniano
abacmut y la posibilidad de una retirada
de las unidades enemigas
la caída de las ciudades de 70.000
habitantes antes de la guerra sería una
victoria simbólica para Moscú y le daría
más fácil acceso a urbes más grandes de
toniesk como kramatowsk y eslobians
sigan con nosotros
[Música]